صدم أحد المشتبه بهم في سيارة
ضابطي شرطة في الكابيتول عند الحاجز الأمني
جمع الكابيتول ثم
زل من السيارة حاملاً سك
نًا.  في الوقت الذي
أطلق فيه ضباط شرطة الكابيتول النار على المشتبه به
، طعن أحد الضباط على الأقل ،
أخبر مسؤول CNN أن
ضابطًا واحدًا مات متأثرًا بجروحه ،
ويليام إيفانز ، وهو محارب قديم في
القوة
يبلغ من العمر 18 عامًا ، أصيب ضابط ثان ، أطلب
منك
الاحتفاظ بالعاصمة الأمريكية  أفراد شرطة العائلة وأفكارك
وصلواتك ، المشتبه به الذي حددته المصادر حيث
توفي نوح جرين في سن 25 عامًا ، كما أنه لم يكن
مألوفًا لسلطات شرطة الكابيتول ،
قال إنه
لا يوجد مؤشر أولي على علاقته
بالإرهاب ولكن الدافع غير معروف
بوضوح أن هذا الشخص كان
يحاول بنشاط  لمجرد الوصول إلى أي شخص
أو أي شيء لا نعرفه ، تم نشر وحدة
من الحرس الوطني
على الفور لمساعدة
أعضاء الكونغرس  معظمهم خارج المدينة
خلال فترة الاستراحة ،
تقول السلطات إنها ليست على علم
باستهداف مشرع معين ،
لكن تم إصدار أمر إغلاق طارئ
للمجمع ، ويأتي الحادث وسط زيادة في
التهديدات المبلغ عنها للمشرعين في الأشهر الأخيرة
ونقاش حول  إزالة المزيد من
السياج حول مبنى الكابيتول
في مكانه منذ أحداث الشغب السادس من يناير التي
استهدفت المشرعين
وتقليل انتشار الحرس الوطني ، كان
بعض الأعضاء على
جانبي الممر يثير الغضب
في الأسابيع الأخيرة ، ومن المحبط
حقًا رؤية الأسلاك الشائكة التي
تسييج الصورة التي  يتم إرساله إلى العالم ، لذا
إذا كان هذا اللون الأحمر لم يعد موجودًا ،
آمل أن نتمكن من العودة إلى الوضع الطبيعي
يمكن أن تؤدي حادثة اليوم إلى عكس هذا
النقاش الذي كنت أعتقد أنه بمجرد
إزالة الحواجز ، كنا
نعود إلى بعض الإحساس بالحياة الطبيعية
ولكن هذا يظهر فقط  مستوى الخطر
الذي لا يزال هناك في حالة اليوم
ثناء على استجابة الشرطة
للأسف فقدنا الضابط إيفانز
اليوم
ب  على العموم ، نجح هذا النظام ، ردت
شرطة العاصمة
، وأوقفته ، وكان النظام
يعمل